hello everyone and welcome to a most
impressive game that was played in Group
B of the twenty20 chasuble Masters
between Fabiana Caruana and an
engineering and well let's allegis dive
straight into it
so already efore is on the board so I
don't even have to play it
guru replies with E 5 we have Knight f3
knight c6 and Bishop to b5 so the rule
opus is on the board and Knight f6 Giri
goes for the Berlin defence and I know
again it's hard to imagine an impressive
game being played in the Berlin but
lately it's very often the case and I
think it it could have something to do
with players using let's say we let's
you're just 0 for their opening or
opening preparation more and more we
have d3 and the Bishop to c5 now giri
prepares the castle we have Bishop to g5
and now h6 are challenging the bishop
are making some room for the king and
also just checking where this bishop
will go do you want to capture do you
want to move it so Bishop to h4 and now
just d6 and here Fabi goes for c3 it's
the the most common move played here a
problem is after let's say Knight c3 you
don't really threaten Knight to d5 it's
not an issue for black black and just
castle and if Knight d5 g5 is very good
for what for black so it's not really a
problem let's say the the Knight
captures with a queen captures Bishop
here and the black is very happy with
everything that's happening so instead
c3 and now he will have support for d4
in the future and here there is a game
that Geary already played with the black
pieces in 2013 in Beijing China he
played this position against the Gothic
um scheme and Bishop to d7 was played
however Gary always works on his theory
and here he goes for castles instead and
it is already as a move 7 that we have a
completely new game so Fabi continues
developing Knight B to d2 and now g5
starts the expansion on the Kings side
and usually could be a bit dangerous
expanding on the same side that you've
castle but here here it kind of works
and here
Fabi has to make a choice does he go
back or does he try Knight captures on
g5 like we've seen in the in the
previous video so instead we have Bishop
back to g3 not going for this
well very interesting this sacrifice
brush up to g3 and now Knight to h5 by
Geary are putting pressure on the bishop
here maybe the bishop maybe the knight
can come to f4 and so on so here our
Father wants the strike in the center
with d4 and first eliminates one of the
defenders
so Bishop captures B captures and now B
for attacking the bishop we've each
captures on d4 and now Nazi captures
although this looks very natural the
pawns might be a liability later on for
example after the bishop moves it's hard
too hard to keep an eye on them for
example now let's say you go after the
bishop you can go a six or a 594 you go
after the bishop but let's say rook e8
and now if you want to keep defending
your pawn it will be difficult since
your King is still in the center of the
board and you don't want to fight over a
pawn while you sacrifice your King
safety so instead we have Knight
captures on d4 by Fabi and now Knight
captures and g3 with H captures and
Queen f6 now with the threat of just
winning upon here captures captures and
captures and there are a few ways you
could deal with this you could just move
the knight you could play something like
Queen a4 could be very interesting guard
the knight this one let's say frog be
just castles Queen side which would be a
really exciting game castles on opposite
sides of the board and with a lot of
open lines here however far be fine and
is the very interesting Queen to h5 he
says okay you you can have the d4 pawn
I'm just gonna gobble up the h6 pawn and
threaten checkmate here and giver says
yeah yeah let's do that
ah he goes for the knight Bishop
captures we have C capture screen
captures and now of course Queen
captures on h6 and now a Fabi
strengthening Queen to h7 checkmate
so Gary has to go back with the Queen so
Queen to g7 defending and only now the
slobby Castle queenside and he says okay
I don't mind training here I'm gonna get
a nice active Square for my rook I also
have to point islands you have three
porn islands so I like my chances here
so far he goes rook to b8 nicely
developing the rook to the semi-open B
file and E 5 now also this comes with
the threat of checkmate so you have to
prevent this if you don't want to
capture then you play e5 so here Fabi
goes for a temper
or maybe not upon sacrifice the Queen
still cannot capture because of queen h7
checkmate so here D captures and in five
and now nights to e4
so a nice positional pawn sacrifice
freeing the e4 square for his knight of
course next move you're threatening
Knight to f6 check which just ends the
game so giver he needs to prevent this
he pushes f6 now is this one of those
positions where it's actually okay to
play f6 we will see our Fabi goes f3 he
strengthens his knight on e4 and here
bishop to f5 by giri and now it's a it's
a question how to continue with white
you've sacrificed a pawn but you don't
have any clear ways of of looking for
advantage like night the c5 you don't
really have any squares the bishop
covers everything so it's hard to say
you can have to go for any any reutlitz
also the bezel very nicely covers that
so here instead Bobby decides to trade
Queens we have Queen captures and g7
King captures and only now Knight the c5
but now Geary finds a most interesting
idea rook to b5 he puts pressure on the
night and now our Fabi has to decide
where to go with an I do go to a6 but
then you allow ideas like rook to a5
with a double attack here
so Fabi decides to go Knight to a4 he's
preparing b3 the strength of the night
and then you can shift the Knights to
beat you and then to c4 which will be an
excellent outpost for the night so here
we have looked a b4 gear even forces
this so b3 defending and now at g4
trying to trying to open up some lines
here and get also the bishop into the
attack however here we have ripped a d2
probably with the idea of either
doubling up on the D file or maybe if we
have a trade here maybe you can double
up on the H file as well could it could
also be possible here Gary goes for rook
F to b8 and it's a it's a really strong
move he's preparing c5 c4 to bust open
the position but if fob is not careful
there's even an immediate threat for
example if you play something weird like
rook H to d1 the threat is rook captures
on a4 and it's just game over for 5e if
the rook is captured rook to d1 is
checkmate since the bishop nicely covers
this diagonal so here Bobby says okay
I'm not I'm not falling for this I'm
just gonna move my knight he plays
Knight
five but this isn't much better so feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find the winning move for Geary while I
give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations
unsporting that it's the exact same idea
that we've just shown and for those of
you who just want to enjoyed show its
rook to c4 with cheque and it was in
this position that Fabiano Khurana
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here if the rook is
captured it's the same upon captures
rook to b1 is checkmate the bishop still
covers this diagonal so there's not
nothing for you to do and if you don't
capture the rook then you can just play
a something let's say King be king b2
but then you just lose a full night so
there's that so I'm very very exciting
stuff and yeah probably where Fabi
position started to you know go downhill
was in the moment when give replay the
g5 it was a it was a challenge he said
do you want to go for Knight captures
captures and captures and then we played
this game were you so it's hard to even
call this a sacrifice you you get two
very healthy pawns in front of the black
King for a piece but this was probably
where where he could have gone for but
he didn't and then after that it was
pretty much pretty much just a very very
comfortable position for black but yeah
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it this is it for the B stage of
the tournament Geary wins the
preliminary stage of the tournament and
maxime beaugeois Grove and similar job
of drop out of the competition and now
the a group and the B group will merge
and we will have a knockout a knockout
event but we're gonna cover more of that
in the next video so I would like to
thank V coups someoneís plunge and
Narendra dalla Jason Steel II and Kyle
Mars for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check too on my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the chest
bull masters 2020 we go into the
knockout event today checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chest world so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day